Rich Paul is probably best known as
LeBron James' agent and the founder
of Klutch sports. In August, 2019,
when the NCAA announced a
bachelor's degree would be required
for agents to represent student
athletes testing the NBA draft,
Paul decided to take a stand against the
rule that directly disempowered athletes
and created barriers for black NBA agents.
You see, Paul does not have a
bachelor's degree, but he represents
several high profile NBA names like
LeBron,  Anthony Davis and Ben Simmons.
The 39 year old's philosophy is
rooted in athlete empowerment,
a threat to establishments on both
the professional and amateur level.
Paul believes in offering more
options to athletes and did so
in the case of the Oklahoma City
Thunder's Darius Bazley in 2018.
Bazley hired Rich Paul in May, 2018
after initially signing a letter of
intent to join Syracuse in November,
2017. Bazley was then hired for a
three month internship at New Balance
which paid him a million dollars and
provided him with training resources
as he prepared for the draft.
Bazley was selected in the first round
of the 2019 NBA draft by the Utah Jazz and
traded to the Thunder shortly thereafter.
This obviously ruffled feathers in the NCAA
and the new rule appeared to be
a response to Paul and agents
who look to do the same in the future.
Hence why LeBron James dubbed it,
"The Rich Paul Rule."
Paul's ability to create more
avenues for his clients was considered
a disruptor to the NCAA system.
A college degree wasn't necessary
for an agent until that point,
some allege, because the NCAA
realized Rich Paul didn't have one.
After significant backlash from
the public and likes of Chris Paul,
Kevin Hart, LeBron James and others,
the NCAA later amended the rule.
And while Rich Paul was able to
continue representing athletes
his own way, it was clear
he played a pivotal role in
shifting the power dynamic between
black athletes, black agents and
institutions for years to come.